the first chain I made from a famous
person was Fat Joe what's a profit
margin on something like that if I'm
gonna charge somebody 50k for a chain my
profit maybe like 10 to 12 000. when
people mention you in their lyrics like
Ferg is the name Ben Baller did the
change do they reach out to you ahead of
time and no it just shows up when Dane
you're surprised first time I heard
Plain Jane was like in January 2016.
it's one of the only four rap songs that
called Diamond 10 million sold something
like whoa how did that impact business
afterwards it took things to a whole
different level who reaches out to you
afterwards everyone you could think of
really yeah